welcome back to peers welcome downstairs
to the county politician in Indiana
United States is making headlines this
week by well exploring his identity
the councilman is coming out as a
transgender as transgender and a woman
of color Delaware County Councilman Ryan
Webb announced that he now identifies as
an indian-american woman
since that announcement he's received
some support but a lot of backlash many
calling him childish despicable even
calling for things like execution
yeah that's always how the work left
responds isn't it you must execute him
um now he issued a statement after the
fury Ryan Webbie said after much
consideration I've decided to come out
and finally feel comfortable announcing
my true authentic self this is Ryan Webb
he said it is with great relief that I
announced everyone that identify as a
woman not just any woman but as a woman
of color as well I guess this would make
me gay lesbian as well since I'm
attracted to women phoo that felt good
to finally get that out there and start
living my life as my true self well miss
Webb's statement has not been met with
the empathy and gushing support normally
extended by the work Community some have
even demanded that he resign they resign
well
that he has basically made a hate speech
in this post on April 11th
and I feel that he should resign and if
he doesn't I would I would look at
County Council to talk to legal and see
what they can do about removing him
because he has created some hate and
Discord and divide what the transgender
population here in Muncie
he must be executed he must be canceled
he must be fired it's the usual
predictable response to what was
obviously a joke but it was a smart joke
because actually what he did was expose
the farce of Limitless self-identity
like myself identified on International
women's day as a black lesbian why
shouldn't I be able to if you can
identify anything you want Esther's
cackle when I said that went around the
world well Ryan Webb joins me now uh
alongside talk to these Nicholas Thorpe
Mr Crackers I just said well Ryan thank
you for joining me so I did chuckle
because I had a similar thing myself
which you may or may not have heard
about when I did a similar stunt uh but
you were making the same point I think
which is if we really want to have a
world where anyone can identify as
anything well why shouldn't you be able
to identify as a woman of color
well Pierce uh you're absolutely right
and I I appreciate it I want to thank
you for bringing me on the show and uh
as a fellow lesbian woman of color
um I feel we have a deep connection here
but you're right they've uh they've laid
the groundwork they set it up where
anybody can be anything that they want
uh just by simply declaring it and um
you know that's what we're doing here
and uh turns out that they don't really
feel as strongly about that and believe
it in their soul as they would make you
believe because um I wasn't really as
accepted in the beginning as you would
think someone of my stature would be
yeah and the reaction was unbelievably
vicious people calling for you to be
executed of course they wanted you fired
of course they wanted you canceled and
all entirely predictable because it's
fine for them
on the other side of this debate to
identify as whatever they want
but the moment you dared to identify as
what you decided you wanted to be for
that day all hell bracelets it's the
double standard
well uh predictably uh the political
left they they always implode on their
own ideology
um I've I've made a statement that I'm
just holding up the mirror uh to them
and they're doing all the damage
themselves I've just stepped back and uh
with their own words and their own
actions they're just uh dismantling
their entire ideology that they've
worked very hard to build up to this
point
um and in my opinion they turned the
clock back uh two three years
um you know just a few days ago all you
had to do uh if you wanted to
self-identify as anyone as you choose is
just declare it and it was a universal
truth that that had to be accepted but
now uh the truth is clear that uh that's
not the case now I've been told you have
to do hormone treatments you have to
start dressing the park you have to wear
the makeup you have to change your
identification
um so you know they've turned the clock
back on their own movement a few years
and it's disappointing to see them give
up so quickly on uh something that they
said they believe in so strongly you
know what Ron I had to chuckle watching
genuine news reports having to report
this legitimately because how else could
they do it without obviously
disrespecting you without respecting
your right to self-identity which it
just made me laugh Ryan I appreciate you
joining me uh Piers Morgan has censored
thank you what are you currently
identifying as
I'm currently uh at the same time I'm
still identifying as a woman of color
and I've I've said uh in a few other
times these Journeys are often complex
and uh you know sometimes we never know
where they're going to take us we could
end up right back where we started I'm
just riding uh I'm just riding the wave
and wherever it takes me that's where
I'll be well I wish you all the very
best with your journey Ryan and thank
you very much indeed for joining me
thank you
all right it's a it's a good laugh I'm
watching the news reports was hilarious
but Nick like I see you've fulminating
as you were listening to this but why
because just as I was doing all he's
really saying is look if we genuinely
are moving to Limitless self-identity
why not this is where it can go we're
not well we are both we're not moving to
limit we are self-identity there's male
female non-binary that's it it's not it
BBC teachers are 100 generals genders is
different genders is different we're
talking what sex is non-binary those but
somewhere between male and female
100 gender identities non-binary is
nothing there are no binaries the BBC
and various other outlets have said I
hear the 72 genders quite often that's
just 72 different ways of describing
something you could also argue there's
only three colors red yellow and blue
but a mixture of all those make
multitudes of colors it's the same thing
with uh how did you feel for example how
did you feel about an American cyclist
Austin killings becoming the first
transgender athlete to women up to win a
women's professional stage race yes
right this has caused complete outrage
and apparently the vast majority you see
towering over the female uh competitors
but here's to say that height
necessarily gives you an advantage
clearly but but a lot of people because
like all these trans athletes when you
look at how they competed as males they
didn't compete with anything like the
success so clearly they have a physical
biological Advantage purely from having
gone through puberty it is indisputable
so anyone who tries the moment I hear
anyone on this side of the trans
activist argument I support trans rights
to fairness inequality but the moment I
hear anyone on that side of the argument
trying to defend what's happening in
sport in women's sport they lose me
because you're denying biological facts
but do you know how many trans athletes
that have more and more competed in the
Olympics more but one okay so here's
what you do with the Olympics let's
remove any specific gender from Olympic
qualification okay what do you think
would happen well that's what happened
what would happen yeah is that how many
women would compete in the Olympics if
it was gender neutral probably just as
many women would compete but on certain
Sports
they wouldn't qualify no women would
qualify okay apart from equestrian and
shooting I think everything else
there is a reason we separate the sexism
yes because men generally speaking
because
women wouldn't win any medals because
it's unfair women so why is it fair for
people who are biological males to put
their hand up and send a woman and
compete against biological feelings
because you're being it's cheating they
don't have to put just put their hands
up and say I'm a woman they have to
transition for two years and for two
years they have to be on hormone
replacement therapy can I ask the
question because I feel how is this in
line with the doping anti-doping
legislation because you on one hand you
have people like Serena Williams who
actually failed a drug test for taking
too much aspirin but you're allowing
biological
bodies full of all sorts of hormones so
their testosterone levels it's not all
women are by the way we're much more
than just a social exactly I agree
well Austin Killers won't be having
periods every month which will affect
training for example I don't have
periods every month well that you're
unique I'm sorry no a lot of women don't
appear any month if you're on your coil
rights a lot of sports women have told
me that is rarely mentioned is one of
the reasons why it's also incredibly
unfair but you just have to see Austin
Phillips towering over the biological
Brian Webb is not being genuine and
that's why the people on the left such
as what is the standard of genuine no
he's he's genuinely sending up the
hypocrisy he's sending up the hypocrisy
as you were saying you know I want to
identify as a black lesbian okay so
nobody is saying that you can identify
as a different race or you can identify
even though it's more logical why can't
race actually is a spectrum exactly
sexism I actually had my DNA done and I
discovered I had no English DNA
whatsoever mainly celt so it was like
Scottish a lot of Irish but hang on
that's six percent Middle Eastern so am
I an Arab yeah six percent of you I can
identify as Arabic yeah but ultimately
you are and you would say a most Arabic
people would say what are you talking
about you're not you're born in England
you're a white guy you're not Arabic
right however it's more complicated far
more complicated than biological sex
yeah biological sex like can you define
for me then what is a biological or what
is a man yeah it's a it's an adult male
and what is that that's a male and an
adult male is an adult male it's a
biology it's pretty easy
fact-based thing but what's it what
makes it Departments of Australia
chromosomes Australia what is a woman
and he replied it's an adult female this
is not difficult but what defines a man
the chromosome and they sell in a male's
body let's play the Prime Minister of
Australia very easily but what is a
woman prime minister an adult female how
difficult was that to answer
not too hard he was just on Time
magazine's 100 most influential lists
named by Justin Trudeau the wokest human
being in the history of planet Earth as
the champion of progressive politics
around the world even he understands
what a woman is you know what's happened
to him today all around Australia
absolutely buried with abuse from the
trans activist mob who say what he said
there was transphobic transphobic for
saying a woman is an female it's nuts